at this altitude I can this episode of
the Tim Ferriss show is brought to you
by LinkedIn more specifically I'm
referring to LinkedIn job recruitment
platform which is a great way to find
and hire the quality talent that you
need in your organization you already
know of course LinkedIn as the world's
largest professional network and in fact
70% of the US workforce is already on
LinkedIn and 22 million professionals
view and apply to jobs on LinkedIn every
week given those numbers it's not
surprising at all that there have been
hundreds of thousands of businesses that
have posted to LinkedIn jobs over the
past year alone and because LinkedIn
considers skills experiences location
and much more they just have better data
to match and promote your job to
potential candidates the most qualified
candidates unlike other generic job
boards businesses have rated linked in
jobs 40% better than job boards at
delivering quality candidates so check
it out go to linkedin.com slash Tim and
get $50 off your first job post that's
linkedin.com slash Tim for your $50 off
today terms and conditions apply
this episode is brought to you by
99designs whether you need a logo custom
website app book cover or anything else
99designs was created to make great
design accessible to everyone
that's you and to make the process as
easy as possible I've used 99 designs
for years now I've used them for book
covers some mock-ups for the 4-hour body
which went on to become a number one New
York Times best seller illustrations of
all different types for the multi-volume
The Tao of Seneca which you can check
out and other graphic design projects
for a long time now and I've been very
impressed by the quality of their
designers and illustrators and you don't
have to take my word for it you should
check out some of my projects at
99designs dot-com forward slash Tim I
really encourage you to take a look
because you will be impressed 99designs
comm forward slash Tim 99designs has
freelance experts in more than 90 design
categories in their platform lets you
work directly with one designer that you
choose if you like their stuff which is
what I did for the town of Seneca or you
can get concepts from multiple designers
and then pick your favorite so whether
you're starting a business or just
looking for extra design help resources
etc 99designs
has a solution right now you guys my
listeners can receive a free $99 upgrade
on your first design to check out your
first free upgrade please visit 99
designs comm forward slash tim and click
the link on the landing page you can
also find their samples of projects from
you guys
listeners who have used 9and designs for
logos apps even product packaging so
check it out 99 designs com forward
slash Tim
hello you crazy kids this is Tim Ferriss
welcome to another episode of the Tim
Ferriss show where it is my I want to
investigate the habits and routines of
world-class performers to try to tease
out the various details so you might
apply to your own life this episode is a
very different format it is an odd one
that has proven surprisingly popular for
reasons that sometimes I don't quite
understand and that is a drunk-dialing
Q&A with all of you guys which I've done
a few times in the last few years and
here's how it works
I solicited phone numbers from listeners
on Facebook and Twitter who want to
receive a phone call from me which they
put into a Google Form then I told
people who the first say 10 to 20 were
going to be by posting it on social
media and then I started drinking and
dialing answering questions and getting
a little frisky along the way in fact
this one came in hot
started after a few preliminary drinks
with friends on a weekend so it's double
trouble I ended up covering topics
including how to reassess existing
projects specifically ones which you've
put a lot of capital on time into using
80/20 analysis and other tools how to
learn to care less about what people
think social perception and how to
minimize herd mentality not saying I'm
perfect in that regard but I'm pretty
good and have approaches for sort of
decreasing the perceived pressure around
all those things a framework for
thinking about entrepreneurship
risk-taking and how to cut your teeth as
a business builder or creator how to
learn to ask better questions whether in
dating or sales and how to let the
silence do the work and so much more and
all that preamble out of the way please
enjoy this tequila fuelled Q&A with all
y'all
hey Danny this is Tim Ferriss I drop my
mic how are you clicking into sixth gear
which is sloppy gear so you catching me
at a good point this is just in the
transition to probably 20% too much
alcohol how are you doing wine are you
right now
oh no we're dealing with straight
tequila so I would say I'm Refik you
four or five glasses in which is I'd say
a pretty good spot it's not completely
haphazard but it is well lubricated
where are you at the moment I am going
you won't Lake City Utah are you I am to
find the fine City of Austin in the
Republic of Texas big fan of SLC though
it's a good spot so how can I assist
this evening what questions might you
have yeah two-part question and so
especially what do they hide from fear
setting which is they've done even
multiple times is what process your
system do you use or have you beaten up
after essentially respectively stop
caring about what other people's
opinions are about you your endeavors
things like that and then how do you go
about building a world-class support
these could both go for a while so I
will try my best to provide a non
[ __ ] answer to either or both in
terms of getting to the point where you
care less or not at all about what other
people think let me drill into your your
personal case so what is what is there
that you might want to do where caring
about what other people think is
inhibiting your ability to execute
whether for yourself or for the world at
large in some capacity yes myself
they're just being entrepreneurship as a
whole
because I belong immigrants of change of
the states when I was four in Germany
family emigrated to Germany from
Yugoslavia and the early nineties with
all of the war and genocide going on
so the immigrant is your nobody unless
you get a college degree so naturally
I'm competing against all of my family
members and cousins who are all
electrical engineers mechanical
engineers etc etc so regardless of what
ideas ambitions or anything else in that
regard a study that I have as longer
than I have a college degree nobody
values and then I got I use kind of
spinning your wheels and wasting your
time got it okay so it's not where it's
so you're not then concerned about what
prospective customers or people in the
marketplace think of whatever you're
starting it's more of a question of
family members great completely getting
out of the herd mentality right we break
away from that and not be bogged down
with this is tougher this is tougher
than the marketplace I would say a
tougher but not impossible I would
recommend a few more a few resources
this is not something that I've
personally experienced but it's
something that a lot of my friends have
experienced it's very very common
as you know with immigrant families
right well there are a lot of my friends
our first generation raised in the u.s.
from India for instance exceptionally
common if you are not an engineered
lawyer or doctor or fill in the blank
then all of your motives and future
prospects are suspect what I have
observed is that if you experience a
degree of success and entrepreneurship
then all sins are forgiven and
ultimately people are very proud of what
you've done
a few resources that I might recommend
that I've found helpful in navigating
may be somewhat similar psychic space
and then I've seen other people benefit
from and that have come up a lot in
interviews on the podcast for instance
as it relates to some similar
life experiences one would be man's
search for meaning by Viktor Frankl the
second which has has come up a lot is
the magic of thinking big by David
Schwartz both of these books are quite
short I want to say both are certainly
no longer than 250 pages and maybe less
than 200 each so you could you could
read each in an afternoon or certainly a
single day and you know aside from that
I would look for people who have done
what you are trying to do namely succeed
as an entrepreneur as the child of
immigrants who have a security focused
mindset if I could be so bold as to
assume that's the case right yeah and
there are many many many such people to
look to whether that's on the on the
name-brand side you can certainly pick
and choose I'm more familiar with many
of the Indian entrepreneurs who have
done this based on spending time with
organizations like the Indus
entrepreneur tie which may or may not
exist any longer but it was certainly a
major entity when I was first getting to
know the Bay Area with nothing to my
name aside from really a piece of [ __ ]
hand-me-down green minivan and I've
always found those stories to be
exceptionally inspiring but also to
serve as proof of concept for you to see
that it can be done and that in fact
those people then end up not just being
reconciled with their family but very
respected and honored and talked about
by their family at the same time so I
think studying historical cases is very
useful in in a situation like this if
you're setting certainly we already
talked about it you already talked about
it I'm not going to belabor that
otherwise I do think that and reach
achada who's an in
actress certainly more than that but
talked about this in tribal mentors when
she I asked her what she did when she
felt overwhelmed or unfocused and she
would ask so what so you really you
write down your fear and this is
different from fear setting but she
would ask so what five to eight times
let's just say and you write down your
fear this happens so what and then you
write the consequence or the preceding
generative year and then so what and so
what and then so what and by the time
you really get to the bottom of one or
two pages you realize that the teeth
just aren't there ultimately I'm making
this up this may not be true for you but
ultimately like your family will love
you no matter what they're just busting
your balls about this particular thing
right or right if you fail in
entrepreneurship you can always go get a
job it may not be an electrical
engineering but if you wanted to and had
to you had a gun against your head you
had to go find a job that your parents
would approve of or your siblings would
approve of you could do that right
or you could at least get on a path that
would lead to one of those jobs and
therefore in and of itself be
respectable to your family members
that's that's another tool in the
toolkit potentially but I think that any
modicum of success forgives all sins
yeah it is it is but look I am NOT I
mean my grandfather was the first of his
family born in the United States on one
side of my family and I never dealt with
having parents who were first-generation
immigrants at all but certainly my
parents have been unable to explain to
anyone what Tim does for a living for a
really really long time I mean it was
very very hard to explain and once I had
a label like author or podcaster they
could be used it made things a whole lot
easier and they were very supportive I
don't want to say my parents weren't
supportive they were
but the labels and the success combined
to give your parents or siblings a story
that makes sense for them and that they
can convey to other people and you can
help them to develop that narrative if
that makes sense and you can also help
them to develop that narrative by
introducing them to documentaries or
books or stories or articles about
immigrants who have become entrepreneurs
yeah
well I'm you know that isn't like my dad
and I'm calling everybody else that came
over here the first generation all
entrepreneur immigrants well then if you
totally just fill the number one
priority for all things no yeah I was
yeah and he and here's here's nothing I
would say it doesn't make you weak to
care about what other people think it
makes you human
as a species Homo sapiens would not have
created
I mean arguably destroyed also but what
we have created without a concern for
social perception and hierarchy that is
just part of the programming that we
experience as a human being and it
serves a lot of productive purposes so I
wouldn't judge yourself too harshly for
caring what other people think
you just have to equally care about what
you think right yeah and a good way to
learn to care about what you think is to
take it out of your head and to put it
onto paper whether that's through fear
setting through the five minute journal
or something like that morning pages and
so on I really find that I cannot
grapple productively with my own
thoughts until I have trapped them on
paper in some fashion yep so hopefully
that helps if it doesn't I apologize but
what what else what else do you have for
me I guess the movie really answered
those in the initial questions if
they're going out building there's a
little class support system they're just
you know getting in the right Network a
group of people are you and Silicon
Valley around a bunch of Angel and even
kind of that tech industry which
initially helped open a lot of doors for
you and kind of broke down a lot of
barriers to help you get your foot in
the door and you know become successful
as you are bored let's get specific so
what do you need a support system for
what are you trying to achieve what do
you think you need one for ranking okay
which is which is totally fine but their
entrepreneurship is very very broad
right right I mean I mean that could be
any no no you don't have to apologize is
it's very common that people want to man
their own ship and carve their own
course but it will help me to think
about the question if we have some
degree of specificity and right if
you're trying to pick and this is
something I've mentioned before but the
five people with whom to associate with
most whether they're in the form of
books in-person mentors or otherwise you
do need the specificity to help you
target whether that's a skill set or
certain types of characteristics that
you want to develop so what do you want
to do in the world of entrepreneurship I
mean who are the people you aspire to be
like what are the projects that you
would love to be a part of and you know
where where are you in that journey also
I mean do you have a company with 10
employees do you have a company with one
employee namely you do you have no
company but you're thinking about
starting something where are you at the
moment yeah yeah I mean through
conference essentially I look at
individual so much luck involving that
maybe where you got to see the people
they bring to the forefront often and
think about them and thus far as pulling
the trigger and doing something and
always going to the point feeling
something building up the systems
essentially having everything sold on my
hands but then just never pulling the
trigger going live right now I work in a
whereas in San francisco-based actually
we're going on first in Utah the federal
Operations Analyst and do a lot of
building in Salesforce but essentially
in the Shia branch I'll do my own thing
and in the realm of social and chapters
and sort of hybrid between the two what
do you want to get what do you think you
might get through entrepreneurship that
you don't get through your current job
gonna be the captain my own ship I've
never never spent well with me kind of
being that guy was okay here's a job
here's of all here's what we think
you're capable of and here's your pay
relatives well we can kiss skill center
is going to handle and then go and plan
your life accordingly to that I'd
essentially just like that more time
you'd be able to join my own life my own
agenda my own calendar do whatever I
want to do my will and then I'm also
recently married on coming up in two
years in May trying to start a family in
the next couple of years so essentially
giving them a one-off a better
foundation than why I had 13 them and I
did one the gaming business well if you
had to start a business tomorrow you got
fired and you need to start generating
income within let's just call it eight
weeks you have eight weeks of severance
yeah we can make it twelve let's be
generous you have 12 weeks you severance
you have health insurance for a year
let's just assume right what would you
do I'd go into e-commerce Shopify and
something going what would you sell
probably apparel apparel why would you
sell apparel now you're grilling me um I
feel like I can find some sort of niche
to still it's Lauren people identifying
with I'm sore group or industry where
there's things out there whether it's a
ball that secures not to Panera
certainly seen a lot of things trending
where it's like crypto investors and
Bitcoin stuff like that I know it's
trendy it's not going to be long term
yeah we just help
get from point A to point B in movement
okay
so here here's what I would here's what
I would suggest as if your brain as a
framework for thinking about
entrepreneurship yeah
entrepreneurship is not mutually
exclusive with employment and truth be
told I think the best way to cut your
teeth as an entrepreneur is doing so
while you have a paycheck I even though
people might think of me as a risk-taker
and someone with a high tolerance for
risk
I don't think of myself that way and for
the record I've interviewed people like
Richard Branson for instance they do not
think of themselves that way either
first and foremost they're looking at
how to mitigate risk so I would suggest
that if that is what you would do as an
entrepreneur that you spend say every
Friday night and Saturday for the next
eight weeks developing that business or
Sunday afternoons and evenings whatever
it might be so that you have the
security of the paycheck you're
receiving you are fulfilling your
obligations to your employer while
simultaneously cutting your teeth and
testing the assumptions that are
underpinning your belief that apparel
and e-commerce could be the business
that provides you with the freedom you
seek and right there is no right answer
here I should also emphasize in the
sense that for better or for worse the
American Dream and the media machines
that exist in our country highlight the
entrepreneurs who seemingly throw
caution to the wind bet the farm and win
big that is not how most entrepreneurs
succeed and in fact that is not how most
humans achieve a life of fulfillment and
financial security and contentment there
is no shame in determining that you are
really really real
good lieutenant or general who can
execute on orders and take something
that would overwhelm other people in
complexity or fill in the blank
perimeter and turn a plan into reality
that is an incredibly powerful gift and
if you do that within the confines of a
company that is in no way indicative of
a lower value than being an entrepreneur
staring off into space and trying to
figure out what the [ __ ] do so I just
even though I mean I am an entrepreneur
because I am a shitty shitty shitty
shitty shitty employee basically and I'm
proud of that in some capacities but I'm
also ashamed of that in other capacities
I mean there are severe personality and
interpersonal deficits that make my
entrepreneurship a necessity and not an
option does that make sense you know and
furthermore I am NOT a good manager of
people I'm very good at figuring out
systems I'm very very very good at
figuring out processes I am NOT a good
manager of people I have certain
Achilles heels including unreasonable
impatience and perfectionism and other
things that lead me to be very difficult
to work with and very difficult to work
for certainly and I and I don't wear
those as a badge of honor I think those
are handicaps in many respects and
there's no way that I could possibly be
the CEO of say a publicly traded company
it would not that I wouldn't pass go in
a situation like that so I have my sweet
spot other people have their sweet spots
and you're gonna have your sweet spot
and I I wouldn't judge yourself harshly
at all if that ends up being sort of a a
special-purpose weapon inside a company
for doing X Y & Z right but the way you
test your assumptions related to
entrepreneurship is by doing so in a
moonlighting capacity so I would I would
take what it is you think you could
do when you quit your job and do that
now I wouldn't I wouldn't test those
assumptions when you've already cut the
umbilical cord and you no longer have
the financial security of a paycheck so
I would do that now
and I've seen a lot of really really
really really good companies start it
that way but you know for the sake of
your sanity and financial security and
also the security of your family to be
if you're considering moving on that I
would absolutely moonlight well that's
going to mean is you're gonna have to
put in extra time in addition to your
job whether it's on evenings or weekends
or otherwise and guess what like that is
what you're signing up for if you're if
you choose to be an entrepreneur if
you're currently working eight hours a
day for at least the first six to twelve
months you're gonna be working you know
12 14 hours a day and almost with that
exception that is a foregone conclusion
so you might as well get used to that in
terms of additional hours per week and
see how you handle it psychologically
physically and otherwise because that is
par for the course for at least the
first six to 12 months without any
necessary guarantee of success in the in
the longer term so those are those are a
few possibilities to consider but I
would absolutely make sure that you
moonlight and test your entrepreneurial
chops and develop your entrepreneurial
skills while you still have full-time
income I think that's a very cautious
but ultimately intelligent way to
approach things all right anything
anything else I know that probably
hopefully that's not completely
underwhelming as recommendation but I
know I would really I would really just
[ __ ] get to it like if you're gonna
be an entrepreneur you don't have to
wait until you quit your job like start
now like start tonight start this
weekend like just [ __ ] get on it it's
like all right set up your Shopify start
doing your market research to determine
exactly what you're gonna test first and
what you can dry test before you do any
manufacturing
or are there options like teespring or
otherwise that enable you to begin to
kick the tires and see if what you think
is gonna resonate and sell will actually
resonate itself so on and so forth um no
and I mean I'm hoping I'm closing
Anderson's on one more question that's
not necessarily business or
entrepreneurship related go for it I'll
try that and try to keep my enumerated
as to a few sentences go for it how
would you or have you kind of done a
foundation on how to balance a caloric
surplus X heavy intensive hypertrophy
regimen routine but also mix in
intermittent fasting or ketogenic or
they're just kind of you know they're
binary you either doing one or the other
yeah I would say you're doing either at
least in my in my case you're doing one
or the other so right now I'm in tequila
chocolate chip cookie like [ __ ]
caloric surplus mode because I've been
having a tough weeks I've been just
completely blowing every rule and yeah
basically aging and dying as quickly as
possible while getting fat in the
process so they're you know there's
blending yeah there's kind of that like
garbage mode which is what I'm in right
now I try not to do that too too often
but I'm I'm currently there because I've
had a [ __ ] of a couple of weeks
and then you have the programmatic
hypertrophy likely high insulin growth
mode which is very much performance
focused and not longevity focused and I
will schedule periods during which I
achieve ketosis and that is very
frequently through fasting so I will and
this is something it should be done with
medical supervision but I will do
generally speaking a minimum of three
contiguous days of fasting per month and
then I will do five to ten day fasts at
least once per year I do
three to four times per year and that is
something that you should speak with
your doctor about but otherwise I do not
generally sustain long periods of
ketosis because I find it so dietarily
boring as all [ __ ] it's awful it's
really really boring and this is
particularly true if you remove dairy
which I've tried to do because my lipid
profile goes sideways if I consume
cheese and dairy while in ketosis which
is something that I've identified which
is not that uncommon in fact so I treat
the I would say performance focused
periods as quite separate from my
longevity / autophagy focused periods
which could involve fasting it could
involve going hypocaloric it could
involve intermittent fasting it could
involve fast mimicking diets Allah
Victor Longo or any number of other
things
I don't currently use anything like
metformin or rapamycin but at some point
could incorporate one or both those and
so on and so forth
but I do treat those as quite separate
much like looking at bodybuilders going
through say bulking and cutting phases
that although that's mostly
aesthetically focused certainly reflects
a certain caloric load and macronutrient
ratio that I tend to alternate between I
don't I don't try to achieve both at the
same time I really appreciate a time
like most ecstatic that I made short
list and then appreciate you giving me a
call and help me get started in dowling
and I'm just you know wondering can I
take you some time in Salt Lake well you
know what I might throw it up on social
when I'm next there so you can keep an
eye out for that but I can't make any
promises beyond that however I would
like to ask that you just [ __ ] get
after it
so we're recording this on a Thursday so
I'd say this weekend
you know get you are now an entrepreneur
starting right now so don't quit your
job and get started on testing the rest
of it in your off hours
I appreciate it of course by a pleasure
have a great night
hello hello
this is Joseph Joseph Timothy this is
Timothy good evening how are you sir I'm
doing well I am all yours so please fire
away what can I help with what kind of
answer if anything first uh like most
people I'm sure I want to thank you for
everything
I found your book through the barbell
shrug guys yeah yeah good crew yeah and
because of them I found podcast and I
found you and found your books and I've
become one of your what thousand true
fans that's Kevin Kelly would say so
well thank you well thank you for
listening well thank you for doing what
you do so so I know you you have a lot
of projects and you're always got a [ __ ]
ton of balls in the air you know and I
consider myself kind of a jack of many
trades or a dilettante and training if
you will and with that comes like I have
a diverse group of interests and things
I like to I'm always trying to pursue
something different and you've talked
several times about the advice that you
were given when it comes to picking
projects that you only have like six
rounds or bullets a year to pull the
trigger on and the more that you try to
if you try any more it pulls you in too
many directions so how do you pick
projects and how do you know what to
pull the trigger on and what to let go
because I'm constantly trying to always
look the next shiny object so this is a
good question it's very timely for me as
well because quite frankly I've taken on
too many projects and also realized that
many of the projects I'm working on
currently are legacy projects in other
words the reasons for starting them
seemed valid a year ago two years ago
six months ago and now with new
information with the ability to test
those projects some of which have
underperformed some of which have over
performed there is an inclination to
continue doing those things we've
invested a lot into due to sunk cost
fallacy and so on and I'm at a point
right now where I'm reassessing not only
the projects that I might do new
projects but really putting under
scrutiny a lot of my current projects
and the way that I'm going about that
right now is number one doing a lot of
hypothetical journaling or it's actually
real journaling but based on
hypothetical questions and namely if I
stop doing X what might be the upside
what might how might it be a good thing
or a great thing
projects that I've put a lot of energy
time capital resources into right and
forcing myself to write out a full page
of bullets or a full page of sentences
for each of these projects that is
consuming a disproportionate amount of
my time primarily so if we're looking at
80/20 analysis which is something I come
back to repeatedly Pareto's law and so
on 4-hour workweek and elsewhere that
I've written about it where I'll ask
myself what are the 20% of projects
right now that are consuming 80% or more
of my time or what are the 20% of
projects or relationships that are
currently producing 80% or more of the
phone calls conference calls email and
other types of in most cases of noise
right and those go on the chopping block
for consideration for elimination and
really what I've realized for myself and
I'm but what I'm going through right now
is recognizing that it's always easier
to look at the shiny new project versus
looking at your current roster and
deciding which children to kill in turn
as it relates to projects so I'm trying
very hard not to say yes to new things
until I've streamlined
my current operations right if your 10%
from the breaking point at all times and
you take on more projects it's a
foregone conclusion that eventually
that's not going to work and so
currently I'd literally just did this
last night I sit down I'm spending time
on morning pages as I've written them
out before so Julia Cameron airing pages
and I'm also doing a 82 an 80/20
analysis on the positive side and that
that applies on a few different
dimensions number one is financial right
so I'm looking at where the income is
actually coming from and what are the
the handful of projects or activities in
my case let's just say podcast and a
handful of other things that generally
generate the vast majority of monthly
annual income and then looking at ways
to streamline that and the question that
I would ask there which is something
I've wrote about I believe in try but
mentors was what might this look like if
it were easy right so yeah the the way
I'm answering your question may be
somewhat dissatisfying but the point
being that it's what I've learned over
time is that you really need to
basically put your current projects in
front of the judge and jury for possible
execution before you even consider what
to say yes to in the new category on the
new category what I might look at our
projects that or tasks that make the
other possible projects and tasks either
irrelevant or much easier for instance
I'm looking at say I'll give you a list
of projects that could be on my plate
one would be doing another book similar
to try but mentors where I have a
hundred to 200 experts of various types
weighing in answering the same set or a
similar set of questions the next could
be I work on a feature film screenplay
that I then intend to produce and direct
or at least produce to have some
creative control over
then I could put on that same list I
want to from soup to not start to finish
beg borrow and steal to get Robert
Rodriguez's attention to from the first
word of the screenplay to the finished
product work on a handful of short films
and and so on and so forth and what what
if I look at those three I might decide
that it's in my best interest to not do
the the feature film first because I
would learn so much through the process
with Robert before doing that that it
would behoove me to tackle a handful of
short films or even one or two so that
that will better inform the decisions I
make with the higher stakes project
which would be the feature film I'm a
further decide that it makes sense to do
another book where perhaps I invite the
20 to 50 figures and entertainment and
feature film and so on who I might
lately want to collaborate with to
contribute in some fashion right and in
that sense I think about the logical
progression that will make each
subsequent project easier and I remember
I heard it said at one point this might
have been from Tony Robbins but I maybe
miss tributing it that we could have
been who knows any number of people in
any case in effect right that we
overestimate what we can achieve say in
a day or a month but we underestimate
what we could get done in three to five
years or ten years and for me it's come
down to realizing that you can do you
can actually do everything just about
everything you just can't do it at the
same time so you have to figure out the
logical progression that puts you ahead
and when in doubt choosing projects that
help you to develop skills and
relationships that transcend any single
given project because you might look at
for instance a single project like the
4-hour chef which was a tremendous
amount of work it was a huge investment
of time it was a suicidal schedule very
proud of the outcome but ultimately from
a commercial standpoint because it was
the first major acquisition through
Amazon publishing it was boycotted
everywhere
and the sales were were quite
disappointing to me certainly because we
didn't have the distribution necessary
and you could look at that as an abject
failure but in doing that for print
distribution I got to know the people at
HMH houghton mifflin harcourt which then
went on to publish tools of titans and
travel mentors both of which ended up
being number one so I developed the
relationship with those people was able
to kick the tires learn their strengths
and weaknesses while also developing
other skills then later informed bigger
projects arguably speaking so that's
that's a long answer but I would
encourage you to also pick up a book
it's very short I've read it dozens of
times called the effective executive in
fact saying it right now makes me
realize that I should reread it myself
but the effective executive by Peter
Drucker would be one place that I would
also turn to as a resource when trying
to make decisions about your time which
ultimately every decision or almost
every decision comes down to so those of
you those would be a few guidelines that
I would suggest at least as having been
helpful for me in the past so so just to
basically figure out what you're doing
that's sucking all the energy that you
could be using on something that you
would care more about and get rid of
those and then go back and if when
you're picking new projects figure out
what your end goal is and figure out the
best project that will get you the
skills to get you the end goal even if
it doesn't take you directly there right
the the progression of projects that
will get you to one longer-term
objective even if it's just a
placeholder that may totally change but
as long as you're amassing skills and
developing relationships those are more
adaptable than is important the report
card for any single project the least of
your thinking longer term so that would
make you though yeah that'd be my
recommendation all right if you have one
more that's short I'll take a stab at it
but otherwise we can okay we can decide
how to how to might
before you always talk about your five
people who are your five people yeah
this is a good question and the five
people change so I would say that very
often they are I mean they're almost
always close friends of mine just by
virtue of the question you know who are
the five people you associate with most
and for those people who don't have the
context I and many other people have
said you know you're the average of the
five people you associate with most
whether it's physically emotionally
psychologically whatever it might be
remotely I still spend a lot of time
with close friends of mine who I admire
and aspire to be more like in certain
ways navall rava Khan Kevin Rose Matt
Mullenweg would would all be on my list
then looking at say people closer to me
geographically now since I live in
Austin Texas
you would have Robert Rodriguez I think
Aubrey Marcus CEO of on it actually has
a lot figured out and not only figured
out but implemented in a very systematic
way that is is hard to appreciate until
you've actually spent a lot of time
around him and so forth and so on
I would say Ray Dalio is also on that
list I don't I don't spend as much time
with him as I would like but certainly
from a reasoning from and planning from
first principles perspective one of the
more impressive guys that you'll ever
come across so those are a few folks on
my list and they all have a lot of
writing and recording out there so it's
possible to learn from them even if you
don't know them directly all right my
friend well I'll tell you what I need to
keep drinking and keep dialing so you
have a wonderful night and appreciate
the questions hi is this Regina
hi this is Tim Farriss I'm looking at
your area code it is late as hell where
you are I'm not going to yeah I am yeah
it's late but it's okay
no you are my last call of the evening
so I appreciate you being awake are you
game for a short conversation oh yeah
yeah all right perfect
well I guess I guess it's what is it
it's probably 2:30 in the morning or
something like that where you are maybe
one in 1:30 in the morning in any case I
am well warmed up and happy to try to
answer any questions you might have
I can't make any quality guarantees but
I will certainly give it a shot so how
can I help
I'll go first thank you for calling my
pleasure and I guess my first question
is since I am the last call how much
have you partake in ah fine question
I've had I would say five moderate
glasses of tequila and soda so I am I'm
very much I'm not gonna say levitating
but I feel light on my feet which i
think is more reflection of the alcohol
than anything else but I'm not
completely incoherent so it's a good
middle ground hatha I would say let's
let's do something I guess my question
for you it would be a good one as I
always have a hard problem with this how
do you come up with questions to ask
people to ask the right questions to be
a good interviewer so that you are
getting to know them very well or
getting the right answers or the answers
that are interesting for your listeners
the way I approach that is not thinking
of my listeners at all quite frankly I
ask the questions that relate to
personal pains or personal goals or
dreams that I have and I assume that
that will apply to some percentage of my
listeners but it's a very personal
journey for me and there's a bit more
planning to it in the sense that if I'm
talking to someone who is very very
frequently interviewed who has a lot of
public exposure then I will try to avoid
questions they were frequently asked
for the first say twenty or thirty
minutes of the interview but if we're
looking at the overarching approach I
would say it is intense curiosity and a
focus on my own personal needs that
drives the questions I ask okay that
make sense you've been asked quite a lot
of questions and you've sold quite a lot
I asked over the years about things that
we already had questions for I would
like to know the attitude cuz I struggle
with that just in general personally
because I'm more of a listener than a
talker mm-hm
so even amongst like I'm dating or a
friend or something like that I find
that hard to come up with questions and
make the other person feel like I'm
interested because I'm usually the type
of person that's like anything that I'm
told or how things just unfold naturally
is how I I guess I feel comfortable just
learning about someone the questions
don't have to be yah mean the questions
don't have to be sophisticated at all in
fact one way to ask questions is just to
be quiet so I was you know told by Cal
fuss man who wrote the what I learned
column for Esquire for decades well
primarily wrote that column interviewed
everyone from George Clooney to
Gorbachev to President Bush and so on
and every single celebrity in between he
told me at one point let the silence do
the work you don't have to ask questions
per se to be a good conversationalist
but there are also very very short
questions that you can ask following
almost any statement from someone else
such as you know what did you learn from
that or how did that make you feel there
are they're very very short questions
that you can ask that can then prompt
someone to talk for 2 to 5 to 10 minutes
it doesn't have to be anything
groundbreaking or particularly
innovative and in fact if you try to
come up with really clever questions it
very often comes off
disingenuous or artificial so simple
tends to work really well in my
experience okay well I guess like to
piggyback off of that my other thing is
that I always feel like I'm asking a
question that might be a little too
personal
so you ever feel that way like when
you're thinking of things we're flowing
with a conversation like can I ask a
question or this much will be an example
of a question you might ask that would
be too personal sometimes I guess is for
me I'm a type of person that I grew up
like as a child I was younger I grew up
with a lot of my family members being
older because I'm the youngest so I was
always in that situation where it was
like you know child space and adults
please you don't ask that question or
you know you only talk when spoken to
kind of thing like when I was younger
and it's kind of rolled over so II mean
even something as simple as if I'm
dating someone over like asking
questions get to know each other asking
anything like how to know which
questions asking about the past they're
asking about you know past people they
stated or things like that like how you
know what happened at the end of the
last relationship sometimes I feel like
that question might be a little too
personal for someone just asking them
off for that and I kind of wait for that
conversation to be brought up by them so
that it's part of the way they're
comfortable with so I guess that kind of
stops me from asking a lot of the
questions that I am curious about
because I don't want to come off too
forward uh well I don't know if the
questions are personal they might just
be too early right so in a context like
that
you don't want to jump from like the
intellectual equivalent of like a pat on
the shoulder to like heavy petting in
ten seconds flat right you don't want to
just emotionally sideswipe someone where
they're like holy [ __ ] like this woman's
asking me about my most embarrassing
humiliating moment of my life and we
barely got drinks already
right okay this is this is too much for
me to handle is that the only context or
there other context is it primarily in a
dating context that you're concerned
about this or there other context
this affects you um well for the past
year I'm still learning how to be a
travel agent so you know like in sales
it's asking the qualifying questions ask
migrate questions asking questions that
builds rapport so sometimes you know
like you bring someone then some people
tell you things that you may not have
even wanted to know but they just kind
of roll along with the conversation and
they let themselves like they just talk
and that's kind of where I feel more
comfortable but then when it's an
instance where you have someone who you
want to try because I'm kind of an
introvert so it's a lot easier for me to
listen to someone else talk when I
should you try to facilitate that
conversation to make it flow so that it
does seem natural like I'm having a
conversation with something but also
getting the information I need to give
them the product that they're looking
for because they don't know necessarily
whether it was for us or they've come to
us so I have to ask them the questions
to get those answers to prepare that's
something that makes them feel like I
understand yeah totally so the first and
foremost being an introvert is not a
handicap I am very much I would view
myself as an introvert who can pretend
to be an extrovert for his limited
periods of time yeah don't get fancy so
for instance when someone's telling you
something you can just say tell me more
about that really give me an it give me
an example could you tell me more about
that how does that make you feel why is
this important
I mean there are a hint there are
questions like that which are very very
simple that keep someone talking and
eventually they're going to give you
that nugget of information that helps
you to better design a solution for them
or find the answer to a specific need
they had that which they couldn't
articulate if you simply ask them what
do you need they wouldn't be able to
give you the right answer so I mean if
you really just had five to ten of these
follow-up questions noted down on a
piece of paper in front of you you would
be able to pick and choose which by the
way is exactly what I often do or did
at least for the first hundred podcasts
that I kind of on this show so it's it's
there's no shame in that I think that
it's very very helpful to have a go to
portfolio of follow up questions which
are very very short and very very simple
to keep people talking in in at least a
sales contacts and that's true for in my
experience for dating as well if you
didn't want to ask about how their last
relationship ended right you could ask
them like well how did you end up using
tinder like how long have you been doing
that or not what led you to them right
you can ask questions which get them to
the same end which out with without
coming off as like the psycho who's
going for the jugular right away you
don't I mean and like trust me I've been
I've been that person right like I get
it but it's like you can you can you can
kind of tiptoe around it while leading
them to the story of what brought them
to where they are today without being
exceptionally direct about it and for
instance if I am interviewing someone
who's dealt with a scandal and my
podcast isn't about scandals it's not
about gotcha but maybe I want to explore
the emotional terrain that reflects how
they reacted to some very difficult set
of circumstances if if I ask them
directly how did you respond to this
event that happened when such and such
person accused you if such a such thing
they're gonna shut down that is a
non-starter but if I ask them and I know
something happened within the last three
years and I asked them you know could
you could you tell me people listening
to this podcast will think based on your
bio based on all the successes you've
had that every time you step up to the
plate you hit homeruns and I feel like
that is inspiring on one hand but very
intimidating on the other so I'd like to
try to humanize you a bit can you tell
us about a really difficult
situation or circumstance in the last
handful of years and how you're spotted
to it right framing it that way opens
the door to allow them to introduce it
without hitting them with a full frontal
assault that is gonna make them
defensive okay right that make sense
yeah
so that's that's an indirect way to
approach something that allows someone
else to feel like they're taking the
initiative and introducing a topic that
may be uncomfortable to them yeah and I
think that's my biggest problem is
because I'm afraid to ask the question
in any way so I don't and then the other
person maybe feels like although she
knows she's not a conversationalist or
she doesn't care to ask anything about
me because she never asked any questions
that are you know deeper than the
typical questions so I can ask indirect
questions that makes the conversation
start flowing and gives them control
over what they tell me
furthermore I would I would recommend
that you practice when it doesn't matter
right so don't just practice with sales
prospects don't just practice with
people you're dating you have the hots
for and that you want to have you know
babies with don't do that like wait like
actually you know I mean we're like oh
my god
yeah this one could be the one like
that's not the time to practice the time
to practice is when you're like talking
to like [ __ ] Joe Blow in line at
Starbucks you're like I don't give a
[ __ ] well this guy thinks like that's
the time that's the time to practice and
it's this it's the same skill set it is
the same toolkit is the same portfolio
of go to questions that you can utilize
on a regular basis so you develop a
level a baseline level of comfort with
this repertoire so that you can then as
second nature use it very naturally when
it matters so that would be my one of my
recommendations is practice when it
doesn't matter whether that is
negotiating a pick-up line a follow-up
question a simple way of bridging one
topic to the next really go out of your
way to practice when it
doesn't matter yeah that makes that make
sense so then my other question would be
to follow it from that how I actually
don't have a lot of situations where I
could ask those questions oh it doesn't
matter because I pretty much just go to
work go to the gym and then come home
yeah so I mean well actually I guess
I've kind of might've been doing that
because I across it so it's you know
like eight people ten people with their
classes the times that I go to and I've
kind of already been trying to talk more
with people at class as opposed to as I
go into class going to the shower and
leaving and I'll kind of already been
doing that but I guess I can start
making a set list of follow-up questions
that help move the conversation along to
get to know people who are talking about
that definitely helps having things that
already because I work better that way
when I kind of already know how I'm
supposed to do things yeah I mean you
have right get an index card write down
the five questions and just make it
happen you're not gonna find time to do
it so you have to create time to do it
and that could be you know the boyfriend
watching the dog while his girlfriend's
doing some god-awful you know Francis
CrossFit workout or whatever that's
alright that's the guy you're like
alright that's my dude that's the guy
I'm practicing on you walk over like hey
what's your [ __ ] dog's name oh cool
really like how do you choose that dog
oh well what's the story behind that
right that's another good question
like what's the story behind us huh
how'd you decide on why huh that's
interesting that's interesting to me
tell me more about that
right like tell me more about that it's
such a lazy useful statement okay how
did you decide that how did that make
you feel that sounds crazy I don't know
how I'd respond to that okay boom then
you have another three you just bought a
three to five minutes story and just
practice that stuff you have to you're
not gonna find time to do it so you have
to make time to do it if you make it a
priority it will serve you if you don't
make it a priority it's not going to
help you so that would be in my drunken
stupor
you're like line that may or may not
help so I think that was a very coherent
answer to my questions fantastic
well I should let you get some sleep and
I should probably also take my dog out
for a walk and do the same thing so
thank you for calling my pleasure and
good luck this stuff honestly listen to
my first few podcasts especially the
first one when Kevin Rose is busting my
balls it's rough it's really really
rough this is a craft this is something
you can learn and practice and I really
believe anyone can get better at it
because it is so straightforward if you
make the time how you can deliver
questions to humans you encounter it's
not it's not difficult or it's not
complex you just have to put yourself
out there and endure a small amount of
discomfort with the uncertainty of how
someone will respond and if you're
willing to do that you can get a lot
better at this in a very very short
period of time hey guys this is Tim
again just a few more things before you
take off number one this is five bullet
Friday do you want to get a short email
from me would you enjoy getting a short
email from me every Friday event
provides a little morsel of fun for the
weekend and five bullet Friday is a very
short email where I share the coolest
things I've found or that I've been
pondering over the week that could
include favorite new albums that I've
discovered it could include gizmos and
gadgets and all sorts of weird [ __ ] that
I've somehow dug up in the the world of
the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I've read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to for our work
humm that's 4-hour workweek calm all
spelled out and just drop in your email
and you'll get the very next one and if
you sign up I hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by
99designs whether you need a logo custom
website app book cover or anything else
99 designs was created to make great
design accessible to everyone that's you
and to make the process as easy as
possible I've used 99 designs for years
now I've used them book covers some
mock-ups for the 4-hour body which went
on to become a number one near Times
bestseller illustrations of all
different types for the multi-volume the
Tao of Seneca which you can check out
and other graphic design projects for a
long time now and I've been very
impressed by the quality of their
designers and illustrators and you don't
have to take my word for it you should
check out some of my projects at
99designs dot-com forward slash Tim I
really encourage you to take a look
because you will be impressed 99designs
compo / Tim 99 designs has freelance
experts in more than 90 design
categories in their platform lets you
work directly with one designer that you
choose if you like their stuff which is
what I did for the town Seneca or you
can get concepts from multiple designers
and then pick your favorite so whether
you're starting a business or just
looking for an extra design help
resources etc 99designs
has a solution right now you guys my
listeners can receive a free $99 upgrade
on your first design to check out your
first free upgrade please visit 99
designs comm forward slash Tim and click
the link on the landing page you can
also find their samples of projects from
you guys listeners with views 99 designs
for logos apps even product packaging so
check it out 99 designs dot-com forward
slash Tim this episode of the Tim
Ferriss show is brought to you by linked
in more specifically I'm referring to
Lincoln's job recruitment platform which
is a great way to find and hire the
quality talent that you need in your
organization you already know of course
LinkedIn as the world's largest
professional network
and in fact 70% of the US workforce is
already on LinkedIn and 22 million
professionals view and apply to jobs on
LinkedIn every week given those numbers
it's not surprising at all that there
have been hundreds of thousands of
businesses that have posted to LinkedIn
jobs over the past year alone and
because LinkedIn considers skills
experiences location and much more they
just have better data to match and
promote your job to potential candidates
the most qualified candidates
unlike other generic job boards
businesses have rated linked-in jobs
40 percent better than job boards at
delivering quality candidates so check
it out go to linkedin.com slash tim and
get $50 off your first job post that's
linkedin.com slash Tim for your $50 off
today terms and conditions apply
[Applause]
you